Welcome this afternoon. I think we're going to get started with the
session. And I want to thank you all for coming and
to
introduce you to our wonderful panel.
So my name is Shauna Hudson. I'm one of the Health Disparities
Co-chairs for Stand Up To Cancer, a member of the Cancer
Prevention and Control program at Rutgers Cancer Institute,
and it's my pleasure to be the moderator for this session.
So today, we're going to be talking about strategies towards overcoming
cancer health disparities, and really highlighting the portfolio of
work that's been funded by Stand Up To Cancer over the past few
years. So we have three presenters who are going to be with us today,
and I'm going to do their introductions.
The first is Dr. Jennifer Haas, who is the director for the
Center for Primary Care Research at Massachusetts General
Hospital. She's a clinician investigator in the Department of
Medicine and in the Division of General Internal Medicine at Mass
General Hospital. She's the co-leader of the Stand Up To
Cancer Colorectal Cancer Health Equity Dream
Team, and this dream team focused on looking at community
collaborations to advance racial, ethnic, and
equity in colorectal cancer screenings. So Dr.
Haas joins us today, and she's going to be talking about her team's work
on mailed outreach for colorectal cancer screening kits in
community health centers. Following Dr.
Haas, we're going to have a presentation from Dr.
Nina Bachael, who's the Associate Director of Community
Engaged and Equity Research at, and also the co-leader of
Cancer Prevention and Control at the Tisch
Mount Sinai Cancer Center. She also serves there as their
co-director for the Center for Health Equity and Community Engaged
Research.
Dr. Bachael is a disruptor. Her work has really been focused
on health equity, and it's a health equity
breakthrough team for Stand Up To Cancer, and their project is
called DISRUPT, which stands for Diversity and Inclusion
in Research Underpinning Prevention and Therapy Trials.
So she's going to talk about the work of that team and how they're
working to help recruit patients to clinical trials.
And then finally, we will have Dr. Robert Winn, who is currently the
Director of the Lipman and the Lipman Chair in Oncology
of VCU Massey Comprehensive Cancer Center.
And beginning in June, we are very excited to have him join us on
the East Coast, a little further north, closer to New Jersey, where I'm at,
as he becomes the Cancer Center Director for Fox Chase Cancer
Center. So Dr. Winn is the leader of our Stand Up To
Cancer Lung Cancer Health Disparities research team,
and he's going to be presenting their work with the Southeastern Consortium
for Lung Cancer Health Disparities.
So, looking forward to all of these presentations.
We'll have some time for Q&A after each one of the presentations,
and look forward to hearing what you have to say as well.
So with that, why don't we get started? Thank you.
All right. Well, good afternoon. Thank you all for giving up the
beautiful sunlight out there to come hear our talks.
We really appreciate it. And thank you also for your
persistent interest in health disparities.
It really remains an important problem
for our country. So, as Shauna
mentioned, I will be presenting the results of our pragmatic
trial that was designed to test the effectiveness of two
mailed outreach interventions to increase colorectal cancer
screening in community health settings.
And I want to acknowledge our
large multidisciplinary team, who you can see named here,
as well as the support of our participating sites, as well as our
funder, Stand Up To Cancer.
First, I want to give you a little bit of background.
In the United States, community health centers, or CHCs, provide
primary care services to nearly 34 million
people, most of whom are low income, uninsured, or
from racial, ethnic minority populations.
This is currently about 10% of the US population, and
unfortunately, as more people lose insurance, it is anticipated that
this population will grow. Although colorectal cancer, or
CRC, remember that, that's an important distinction, CRC
versus CHC, is the second leading cause of
cancer-related mortality in the US, CRC screening is
underutilized, especially in community health centers.
Stool-based CRC screening modalities are commonly
used in community health centers.
However, effective stool-based screening requires follow-up
of all abnormal results with a follow-up
colonoscopy, and these rates in community health
centers are also particularly low.
This slide just gives you a little bit of sense of where
colorectal cancer screening rates are in the United States.
So about 60%, which is what this dotted blue line
represents.
And
you can see from the bar graph that community health centers have
continued to perform well below the national screening
rate over the past 10 years, recently just over
40%.
Additionally, follow-up colonoscopy rates after an abnormal stool-based
test result are also very low in community health centers, and published
reports suggest that only 18% to
62% of people with an abnormal stool result
will get a follow-up colonoscopy.
So, very discouraging
results.To just to focus on the importance of this
point, community health centers often use stool-based tests
to screen for colorectal cancer. Stool-based tests are
inexpensive and readily available.
Stool-based CRC screening modalities include fecal
immunochemical testing or FIT and FIT-DNA, which
is currently sold under the brand name of Cologuard.
Both can be mailed, allowing for population outreach.
These stool-based screening modalities, again, are a two-step process that
require follow-up colonoscopy if they're abnormal.
Lack of colonoscopy after an abnormal stool-based test is
associated with poor colorectal cancer outcomes,
including increased colorectal cancer incidence,
mortality, and late-stage diagnosis.
So now on to our study, the Community Collaboration to
Advance Racial Ethnic Equity in Colorectal Cancer Screening,
or CARE-CCRS Study. It's a little bit of a mouthful.
Compares two population outreach approaches to increase CRC
screening uptake among screening-eligible adults who receive
care in community health centers.
And aim two was an exploratory aim where we
sought to increase the completion of follow-up colonoscopy
after an abnormal stool-based test result.
So either one of the arms, FIT or FIT-DNA, through patient
navigation to address barriers to follow-up.
So now I'll move on to our design and methods.
We conducted a pragmatic randomized trial in two U.S.
regions that included four community health centers in Greater Boston
and four community health centers in Los Angeles.
In addition, we included a parallel non-randomized site
at a tribal clinic in Rapid City, South Dakota.
At each of these centers, we identified individuals aged
45 to 75 who were due or overdue for
colorectal cancer screening. We included patients with a
recent primary care visit and those who had an English or
Spanish language preference.
We excluded people who did not have a physical mailing address or a
phone number listed in the electronic health record because both of
these were required for population outreach.
We also excluded individuals with prior documentation of colorectal
cancer, adenomatous polyps, Crohn's disease, or ulcerative
colitis, as these individuals are at increased risk and are
not typically appropriate for stool-based screening.
We compared two competing strategies, FIT versus
FIT-DNA. FIT is an annual test. We have listed
some of the test characteristics here on the slide.
FIT-DNA can be done every three years, reflecting its
greater sensitivity for both colorectal cancer as well as
advanced adenomas, which you can see down here in the comparison.
But you'll also note that FIT-DNA has a somewhat lower
specificity than FIT.
Clinics were matched by region and size and then
randomized to either the FIT or the FIT-DNA study arm.
In the FIT arm, eligible patients were mailed an invitation
letter to participate in the study, as well as an
infographic highlighting the importance of colorectal cancer screening.
Two weeks later, patients were mailed the CHC's
usual brand of FIT kit, as well as a one-page
English and Spanish instructional sheet pictured
here that gave people instructions on how to
complete the test. And you'll notice that this is largely an
infographic with minimal words because we were really
targeting people who may have a low literacy level.
We also included prepaid postage and a mailer,
and patients also had the option of dropping the FIT kits off at the
clinics.
And then finally, we sent up to three text messages to patients in the
FIT arm. The first text message was sent before the FIT kit was
mailed, letting the patient know that they would receive the kit in the mail
soon. And then the second and third text messages were reminders to
patients to complete the test.
In the FIT-DNA arm, we also included the similar
letter and the similar infographic with information about how
to complete the kit.
And then
the FIT-DNA kit was mailed by Exact Sciences,
who is the manufacturer of the FIT-DNA kit,
and included materials on how to collect the sample with their
standard instruction and how to complete the test.
In the FIT-DNA arm, patients received the standard patient
navigation program provided by Exact Sciences.
And
this consisted of mailed letters, phone calls, emails, and text
messages to patients reminding them to complete the tests.
Individuals in both arms with an abnormal result received
navigation to colonoscopy.
Next, I'll transition to the results.
This is a little bit of a busy slide.
Forgive me, but this is a description of our study patients
just in the randomized sites in Boston and LA.
I will show you the demographics of the South Dakota site in a second.
We enrolled, as you noticed, just over 5,000 patients.
Overall, the mean age was 55, 59% were
female, 75% were Hispanic or Latino,
7% were non-Hispanic Black, and 15% were non-Hispanic
White. 50% were covered by Medicaid and 12% were
uninsured, with the remainder covered by Medicare or
commercial insurance. Of note, there were more Hispanic
patients in the FIT-DNA arm versus the FIT arm.
And this is shown in the red circles.
There were no differences in insurance.
And although we tried to balance the sites during the
randomization process, this was not totally possible,
and so this demographic difference resulted from differences in the
clinics at the time of randomization.
These are the characteristics of the patients who were enrolled at the
non-randomized tribal site. There, we enrolled just over
800 patients. The mean age was slightly older,
60 years, 56% were female. All of the patients
were American Indian, Alaska Native, and all were covered by the
Indian Health Service.This slide shows
our primary outcome, screening participation within 90 days on
the left. The secondary outcome of participation within
180 days is on the right. For the randomized
clinics, so Boston and LA,
sorry. For the randomized clinics, you can see the comparison of FIT
versus FIT-DNA, and you can see that there was
a significant but modestly, ooh, higher...
I'm not sure what happened here.
It's back.
Okay. All right.
Significant,
but modestly higher return rate in the
FIT-DNA arm compared to the FIT arm,
28% versus 23%. And this difference
persisted at 180 days. Was a little bit
narrower, but still statistically significant.
And you'll notice that in the non-randomized arm, that the return
of FIT-DNA was
also higher.
A little bit lower than in the
randomized site arm. So again,
encouraging that mailed outreach led
to a
significant increase in screening.
This slide shows time to screening in Boston and Los Angeles.
The differences in the two arm became apparent by about 30 days and then
persist through 180 days.
This slide shows differences in screening participation at 90
days for different subgroups. And you'll see that overall
screening completion was higher
in Boston compared to Los Angeles, so
28% versus 23%.
The differences between the FIT and the FIT-DNA
arms were largely driven by Los Angeles, so
28% versus 18% versus
28% and 29%.
And there were no differences at the Boston site.
And we think that this was likely because the Boston sites had a
closer association with an academic health center,
and the clinics in LA had much lower
screening rates at baseline, and so
potential for much greater increase.
The other subgroups that we looked at,
we saw greater use of FIT-DNA among
Hispanic individuals
and those with Medicaid or who were uninsured.
But we think that these differences were likely related to the
differences in the different clinics that persisted
despite randomization.
So I apologize for this being a little bit of a busy slide, but I
will take you through it. The top row shows
the actual screening test that people completed.
So this was a pragmatic randomization.
We reached out to people with the modality that was
selected by the randomization, but the clinics could offer
whatever test they wanted. The clinical team, these were all
people who were due for colorectal cancer screening.
And even though they knew the study was going on, if somebody was sitting
in front of them in their office, they may choose to
screen them on their own. And you'll notice that there is some
crossover in the arms. And so
for people in Boston who were randomized to receive
FIT, there were seven people who received FIT-DNA, so the provider
chose that instead. And for people in the FIT-DNA arm, there were
28 people who received FIT. And I think
FIT has historically been a much more commonly used test in community
health centers.
But recently,
I think largely because of the patient support program provided by the
manufacturer, which takes it out of the hands of the clinic
staff, the clinics have gotten much more comfortable with
offering FIT-DNA. And if you look at the LA
sites, you'll see that there was no crossover between FIT and
FIT-DNA. Those clinics don't offer, and still don't offer actually,
FIT-DNA. And in the FIT-DNA arm, again, some
people who receive FIT
and similar crossover in the South Dakota site with some
people who are receiving FIT-DNA.
And then, I think that what you'll see is we
did a couple of different types of analysis.
The first is that we analyzed them in terms of the abnormal
results per protocol, which meant as
randomized. And you'll see that
this looks at the positivity rate.
There were about 100 people in the randomized clinic who had a positive result,
and there were an additional 26 people in South Dakota
who had a positive result.
And you can see what the positive rates were in these sort of different
buckets. You'll see that South Dakota had a very high
positivity rate, and that is largely
because that population was really pretty
unscreened when we got there. And so this was largely the
first screening test for many of these individuals.
The other thing that you'll see is the positivity rate in Boston is pretty
low. That probably was the most screened group.
And the other thing that you'll notice
is that
there was differences between the brands of FIT kit that were
used. And it's known that there are differences in the quality of FIT
kits that were used. And so one of the things that this
study confirmed is that the Boston sites used a quote, "higher
quality brand of FIT kits" than the LA
clinics. And as a result, that's probably one of the things that
contributed to the higher positivity rate in
Los Angeles.So, unfortunately, colonoscopy
completion after an abnormal test result was limited
despite centralized phone-based navigation by study staff.
Follow-up rate was highest in Boston, which is this
column,
and again, perhaps because of the closer ties
to the academic health center, and it was lowest in
LA because of least access to
colonoscopy in that site.
So, with any study, there are both strengths and limitations.
First, in terms of limitations, this was a pragmatic
trial and the different sites used different FIT kit brands
with different positivity rates.
This is a limitation, but again, pragmatic trial and this is sort of what
you see in real life.
We didn't assess cost effectiveness, which, given the differences in the brands,
might actually be sort of an interesting thing.
And we only tailored our results to English and Spanish languages.
We unfortunately could not randomize the South Dakota site because there
wasn't another site in the region that had
stable enough access to mail
that we could do a mail population outreach intervention.
In terms of the strengths, we conducted a pragmatic
study design with a large sample. The study was implemented in
multiple regions with different population subgroups and
community health centers. We also focused on an
under-resourced community setting
and this is increasingly an important source of
healthcare in this country that is unfortunately often
overlooked in research.
And finally, the study fostered academic and community
partnerships that are going to continue and are going to be
leveraged for hopefully some new opportunities.
So, in conclusion, in terms of the study, the CARE study
showed that CRC screening uptake was modestly higher in the
FIT-DNA arm than in the FIT arm, but that the majority of
individuals in both arms remained
unscreened. And we saw regional differences in
uptake and positivity, likely driven by
access to both prior screening as well as colonoscopy and
FIT brand.
Colonoscopy follow-up was suboptimal at all of the sites, despite
navigation. And the CARE study really serves
as an early demonstration of how to implement mailed FIT and
FIT-DNA in underserved settings.
So, there was actually an additional aim in our grant, and it
is the best aim of the grant, and I think
that it was really the best part of this award,
that it included a mentorship aim.
And
we needed to describe how were you going to sort of mentor the next
generation of underrepresented in medicine and public health
researchers. And so we selected three
people when we wrote the application. It included Dr.
Erika Warner,
Dr. Anyane Yeboah, and Dr. Nicolette Rodriguez.
They have all transitioned,
during the period of award, on to sort of the next phase.
Erika got actually two R01s
and is doing great. And the two folks
on the right have both gotten career development
awards. One was sort of taken away transiently, but
then she got it back.
And have actually gone on to get
other types of awards as well. The other thing is
that this mechanism, in addition to the main study findings, which will
actually be coming out relatively soon, there were a
number of sort of spinoff publications that these folks were
able to lead. So it's actually a great opportunity and
as I said, this was sort of the funnest and best part of the aim.
And so, thank you. I'll take any questions, I guess now or at the
end, and this is just a picture of a few folks
at the last Stand Up to Cancer meeting that we were all
able to go to. So, thank you.
Hello. Okay, the microphone is on. My name is Aldenice Ewing.
I'm an assistant professor at the Ohio State University.
My research focuses on digital health interventions for colorectal
cancer screening promotion and partnership with federally qualified healthcare
centers. So I greatly appreciate your presentation.
I have a question focused on overcoming
barriers in working with community health centers.
So in your experience implementing disparity-focused interventions,
what structural or health system barriers have been most
difficult to overcome when working with community health centers?
And what implementation strategies have been successful in
sustaining those interventions within large healthcare systems?
So, it's a great question, and I think what I'll say
is every community health center is different.
And so one of the things that I didn't talk at all about was
that we spent
a fair amount of time at the beginning doing a lot of
qualitative work with each of the health centers that participated,
trying to understand their culture, trying to understand their
workflows, trying to figure out how best
we could address whatever their concerns were.
And the concerns were sort of all over the place.
And I think we also sort of did this with an eye to
sustainability. I think that Cologuard comes with this kind of
wrapping around it,
and we wanted to make sure that we weren't just giving
people a FIT kit, and so we wanted to have sort of a comparable, some
sort of outreach, and these are sort of relatively low
technology, lots of staff
burden, which is why we sort of settled on a texting platform.
That was something that all of the health centers thought that they could
manage potentially.
And so I think it really takes a lot of work, and
I would say that the barriers aren't the same.
And the other thing I'll say is that the South Dakota
site was obviously the most dramatically different than the others.
And the other reason that we couldn't
randomize the sites is that we actually had to give patients an
incentive to participate. The participating
health center really thought that given all of the other barriers that
patients in that setting faced...
um, that we needed to include that incentive.
And, largely, long travel distances, people needed to buy
gas. And so I think that was probably the most
extreme example, but all of the health centers had
barriers in terms of staffing and workflow.
Thank you.
Lovely talk and lovely trial. I'm just curious,
took note that there was a higher positivity
rate in the South Dakota. Did you capture
risk factors like smoking, alcohol, tobacco use,
et cetera?
So, one of the follow-on studies that one
of the junior investigators is working on is
that for the people who had a positive result,
we did a risk assessment. The navigator did a
risk assessment. And so, we did collect
some of that information and,
I would say that the risk...
So we didn't get detailed information on-
Right
... diet and all of those things. But, in terms of the
factors that we did look at, the risk factors were not
dramatically different.
Thank you.
So, you mentioned,
in the different sites that there was a subtle difference, well, maybe not so
subtle, in the availability of colonoscopy.
And I was wondering, since you're still in urban centers where broadly the
capability is there, if you have any thoughts about the fact that no one can
get a colonoscopy outside of a city in the United States anymore.
Any thoughts related to that barrier?
Well, I think it's actually interesting that South Dakota did better than LA.
And folks in South Dakota were driving three hours to get a
colonoscopy, and they oftentimes needed to stay in a hotel the
night before so they could do the prep.
So, I think in LA, it was
most concerned. I think we started this
study in the shadows of the pandemic when facilities were
closed, and there was really a backlog.
But we're writing a follow-on study now,
and I think, there are insurance barriers in terms of
ACOs dictating where you can go in terms of capacity.
Sites maybe not wanting to take payment from
ACOs and deprioritizing those colonoscopies because
they can get better payment from other insurers.
This is my cynicism, but I think the problem is there's
limited capacity. It's hard to get through on the
phone.
It's hard to book a convenient time.
You need somebody who's going to drive you home.
So I think that there are barriers on all sides.
I think patients are afraid of colonoscopies.
They're afraid that this means that they might have cancer.
They don't want to know. So all of those things,
I think, factor into it. It's not probably just as simple as I
can't get a
colonoscopy booked.
Hi, my name's Alexandria Mardanian.
I am the Comprehensive Cancer Control Program coordinator with
Great Plains Tribal Health. So-
Oh, hi.
Kelly says hi, Dr. Haas.
Nice to meet you.
You too. I just want to let you know that we're working with partnerships in North
Dakota and South Dakota with Cologuard and Exact Sciences to expand,
and we're working with the PRC program to try and get those
a little bit more mainstream.
Yeah.
Since we do have to follow that PRC process.
They have to be approved and sent to a committee to be, whether those
colonoscopies will be paid for. There's only so much money a
month allowed and allotted for that.
So we are-
But as I said-
Yeah
... you guys did much better than Los Angeles.
Yeah. So we We're trying to expand more, and I hope-
Yeah. You guys-
... we get to continue our partnership.
I'll put in a plug for, the Great Plain,
Tribal Leaders Health Board. They were sort of an amazing partner in this,
and we're actually in the process of writing a follow-on study-
Mm-hmm
... with Kelly and a bunch of folks there.
That's sort of a follow-on, to this piece.
And so, I think,
it's been a great partnership.
Yeah.
So.
Thank you.
It's been great to visit out there.
Yeah.
And it's a beau-
We can't wait to see you back.
And it's a beautiful facility.
Yes.
It's really an amazing facility.
And we'll take one last question. Thank you.
Thank you. Good afternoon. Cathy Dosas from Virginia Commonwealth University and
VCU Massey Comprehensive Cancer Center.
Just wanted to follow up on the question around the FQACs.
And, we've experienced before in some of our FQACs, as
you said, if you know one FQAC, you know one FQAC.
I'm curious if you guys, perhaps this is not a main part of your study, but
collected information on providers', challenges,
deciding, for example, to provide a FIT.
You randomized it versus like the DNA-based tests.
We know an FQAC in Virginia, for example, where at some
point they were doing the mailers of the FIT cards, and then patients would
bring it back. And it's a small town, some
accident happened, one of those FIT cards being mailed, and
the decision was made that the
post office was not going to be delivering any more FIT kits,
period. They would not touch it. And so that affected a whole community.
And so just-
Wow
... curious around
if and how you guys collected any information, perhaps peripheral,
about that. And if not, are there any plans to have perhaps those
conversations? Because again, we usually focus on, of course, the individual,
but we know that there's different structures that we don't even see sometimes.
Yeah.
Kind of-
So that's a dramatic, um, example
Yeah
We didn't run into anything like that.
I think as far as I know, uh, the postal service
delivers FIT kits in both Boston, LA, or Boston, LA
In South Dakota.
We did, as part of this ramp-in process, talk a lot
to providers and all of the clinic staff in each of these places
to try to understand their barriers.
That's actually a new one. We've heard lots of things, but
never heard that.
I think that
one of the other problems with FIT kits is just
that they have a shelf life, and so if the postal service
doesn't return them quickly enough, they can't be developed.
Or if the patient doesn't write a date on them, they can't be developed.
And so it's sort of more error-prone, or there are
more user errors associated with FIT.
But, the piece of it is that health centers also don't like
FIT because they
don't like doing population outreach with FIT.
They will hand it out in the office and have them return
it to the office because they have to bear the mailing costs.
And so, the FIT kit itself costs two
bucks. But,
the mailer for it is 10 to 11. And so
from the perspective of the health centers, mailed FIT outreach is a
serious cost issue, whereas they don't bear those costs with
Cologuard.
And so as long as the patient is insured and
the out-of-pocket costs for FIT versus FIT-DNA
are the same, unless you have a high-deductible health plan.
And so I think the issue is that it's easier for them
to manage logistically.
Yeah, I think the other message for the health centers is, "Don't buy
a cheap FIT kit. Buy a slightly better FIT kit, and then
you don't have to deal with a higher colonoscopy rate." So, all
right.
Thank you so much, Jen.
How do I find...
I think they're going to bring the slides up in the back.
Oh, they're going to do it? Okay.
Yes.
Okay.
Good afternoon. It's a pleasure to be here talking with folks who are
interested, still, thankfully, in an ongoing
problem of disparities. So I'm going to talk about
our project, which is called DISRUPT,
which is Diversity and Inclusion in Scientific Research
Underpinning Trials.
And,
I've no financial relationships to disclose.
And the way we came about this was really looking
at who's missing from
current cancer clinical trials, from cancer research,
and how does that gap actually affect our trust in the
science? And what we as clinicians, I'm a primary care
doc,
and working with oncologists, what do we actually do and offer to patients?
What can we tell them? So what do we know about recruitment to
cancer clinical trials?
Well, we know that at community hospitals, only about
7% of folks are actually recruited to cancer
clinical trials. At NCI-designated cancer
centers, it's higher. It's almost 22%.
So quite a difference. But the key thing within those who
actually are accrued to trials is that
minority patients represent only 20% of
folks who are recruited to therapeutic trials.
But they actually constitute 42% of the
population. That is a huge disparity.
And when trials lack representation, their
results may not apply to the real world.
So this is an issue of social justice.
Why does this happen? Why are there barriers that block
accrual to clinical trials? Well, the usual.
There are patient reasons, provider reasons, system reasons.
So there's a fair amount of mistrust out there.
There are issues of health literacy.
There are practical access challenges that patients face.
Providers may not know what trials are available, and even if they do, there
are so many time constraints of actually being able to raise
the question and the possibility, let alone actually enroll
someone. Implicit bias gets exacerbated by the
time constraints. And then the systems,
strict eligibility criteria. You have bad renal function, you're not
eligible. And who has higher rates of
hypertension and diabetes and chronic kidney disease?
So really, there are so many different reasons on all different levels as to
why we see these disparities in clinical trial
enrollment. I put this in, this is not our work, and it came
out recently, but
it's very informative in terms of the work that we actually ended up doing
for DISRUPT. This was a project actually out of
the Harvard system. And what they did was they used
AI to increase clinical trial enrollment.
And basically, they took all the patients who had genomic testing,
they
randomized, and they emailed the oncologist...
Well, those who got randomized to the intervention, they emailed the oncologist
with match lists for those patients.
And even doing that, 2.8% consented to a
trial, 2.1% enrolled,
and there was no difference between those who got the intervention and those who
didn't. And so the researcher said, "Well,
clearly there are issues beyond what we were doing
that affect likelihood of enrollment." The other thing in thinking
about disparities is that86% of their
population was white. So it really is not even getting
at a large proportion of the patients that we see.
So what did we do differently? What did we do to address disparities in
clinical trials?
Well,
first of all, we collaborated with folks at
institutions that served Harlem, Northern
Manhattan, and the Bronx. So institutions that are really
serving both
populations that are poor and are
mostly Black and/or Hispanic.
And the way that we approached this was we had three different
aims that we hope will, and are trying
to create institutional change within all of our
systems. And so the first aim focused on community, and
we really want to disrupt norms in how communities think
about cancer research and cancer clinical trials.
The second aim was focused on care delivery.
How do we actually recruit to trials? What can we do to make it easier?
And then the third aim was focused on disrupting, actually,
basic science and trying to get community relevant
research done by basic scientists and also teach them about
health equity. So here's our team.
These are our team leaders.
We included individuals who are either patients or
certainly community representatives in addition to
the folks at... This was at
Montefiore Einstein in the Bronx, so over here.
And Washington Heights Inwood is served by Columbia.
Mount Sinai serves mostly East and Central Harlem and
City College.
So what did we do with community? So we really
worked very hard
to move community from uncertainty to advocacy,
and we started out with community engagement studios to hear
from folks as to what their issues were. So what did we hear?
So we heard research is both a source of hope
and simultaneously, in the same individuals, fear.
We heard that people were actually quite
concerned to the experiences that either they
have lived or their family and friends have gone through.
So the issues of mistrust that were coming out
were actually not due to Tuskegee and Henrietta
Lacks. It had to do with how they were being treated by the healthcare system
now.
So how did we move then from these community engagement
studios? We listened a lot, and we learned,
and there was very strong bi-directional learning, which really ultimately
contributed to trust. From those community
engagement studios, we ended up partnering very
closely with seven different organizations to
co-design projects.
So the whole idea behind co-design is that
you're not outreaching to communities, you're co-designing with
communities. And so these
took very different forms based on what the strengths of the individuals
in these communities, these organizations were.
So we had a writer's workshop. We had CRAVE, which is
creative research as an avenue or a vehicle
for education. And we did this in all different
kinds of spaces, and there was somewhat of a snowballing
of people would come up to us and introduce us to other folks in other
communities, and so that's how the process really expanded and
reach expanded.
Care delivery, and I'm happy to talk more.
You can ask all of the questions about the specifics of what we did.
Care delivery, we really wanted to address the
very different challenges that I talked about before.
And so what we ended up doing was
rather than the way we currently recruit to trials, so right
now, mostly, you have trials, and you find patients who fit the
trials. We wanted to disrupt that, flip it on its
head, and find patients who are at treatment decision points
and then find trials to fit the patients.
So in order to do that, we had to identify patients
every day via Epic, our electronic medical record,
create and use an algorithm to identify patients at treatment
decision nodes, and then
from those, identify who consent them and then
classify them and also classify all the open
trials at the three participating cancer centers and then match
them. And then we would educate patients about clinical
trials in general, and then we would send this match list to the
docs before the treatment decision-making visit, and we would do that via email,
and we would send it to the patients.
And each one included embedded links so they could get more detailed
information. For the patients, it was in English and Spanish and a
simplified description of what the different trials
were.
Oops.
So,
so far, we actually just ended enrollment.
So we have to date enrolled 579 patients.
58% of them are minority, self-identified as minority.
And what you can see here is that
we actually recruited more minorities than
whites. And among those who were recruited, there's
absolutely no racial ethnic difference in who was matched to a
trial.There was a difference, not surprisingly, in who
was truly eligible. This is basically due to the difference in
comorbidity loads that minority patients tend to have.
And once you actually were eligible, no racial
difference in actual enrollment in a clinical trial.
So this just gives you a sense of what we actually
went through in terms of identifying patients at treatment decision
points. And so this is just one of the institutions, and you can
see of patients who are identified at a treatment decision
point, if you're new, clearly you have to have a different treatment.
You have to have some treatment started.
If you're an established patient, you have to have a scan to determine whether or
not you have disease progression.
The algorithm was actually pretty good at being able to
identify people who had negative scans, who
are not eligible for trials at that point,
and don't need to be manually reviewed to see if anything else has to
happen.
Not so good with the positive scans or the mixed scans.
But the bottom line about the algorithm is at least this actually
reduced manual review by
35%. So still, a significant time saving in trying
to identify patients.
The algorithms work variably on being able to actually
stage the patients because we needed that, obviously, and biomarker
receptor status in order to be able to match them to appropriate
trials.
And you see, there's variability.
And our biggest challenge with this is timing.
So for example, for lung cancer patients, they would come in in the morning
and get a scan.
We didn't have the results of that scan in the EMR to be able to even
run an algorithm on it by the time they saw their physician in the
afternoon.
When we did, on the retrospective sample, use these same algorithms,
actually, the accuracy for staging goes up to over
90%. So this, we still are working on this piece.
And then just to give a sense of sort of that funnel
of all the folks who are coming in. So out of more than
70,000 patients, our IT
identified folks at a treatment decision point of a little less
than 14,000. But refining the
algorithms brought it down much further.
Then we were able to consent patients.
I will say that we had a much higher refusal rate than we
expected, and most of that was due to the fact
that it's an extremely emotional time for people,
and they just did not want to deal with research, period.
But once we actually did get folks consented, you can see that of those
who actually were eligible for trials, we were able to
enroll 27%. And to put that into perspective, at the
NCI centers, it was a little less than
22%. So it looks like we're doing pretty well.
So what did we learn from the oncologist?
We actually had a 97% participation rate
of all the oncologists taken care of.
This was focused on breast, lung, and liver cancer patients.
And we got 100% response rate from all of them on the survey.
But the biggest things that really would interfere with, from their perspective of
who they'd offer trials to, were patients who had family
responsibilities and work time constraints.
Which is really important because
when we talk to patients,
you can see that family responsibilities were actually much more
common among our Black patients as compared to white
patients and other access barriers.
So,
the likelihood of being offered
a clinical trial
seems likely to be less for minority patients.
In fact, when you look at what
patients' attitudes are towards clinical trials, they're actually pretty
positive.
We didn't make that much of a difference
with the education that we did.
Blacks, it got a little bit better, but it's not statistically significant.
But the bottom line about this is there were no racial ethnic differences
in patients' positive attitudes about clinical trials.
And there was also no racial ethnic difference in patient report of the
doc talking to them about clinical trials.
Oops.
All right. Our third aim was focused on disrupting the
research and education
approaches. And
what we did towards that end was we actually funded
pilot studies that were focused on
disparities. And we required that
each of these studies must have a community scientist because we
really wanted to stimulate research that was relevant to
the communities. What we learned in that process
was we actually needed to do some work to train community
members who were interested to be able to be active participants in
this. And so we created a community scientist institute,
which is now a certificate-granting program at the City College of New York.
And the CSI has already graduated 26
individuals who have been participating, not just in the pilot
studies that we funded, but actually in additional research
proposals that have gone into the NIH.
In addition to that, and Jen talked about the importance of
mentoring, we wanted to bring a lot of the
experiences and exposures to community and working with
community to really embed that in the next
generation. And so we created a student health ambassador
program. So we involve students. We had folks from
York College, from NYU, from City
College.Joining in in the
different community-involved events, learning how to be able to
work with community and how to talk with community.
So far, we've trained 14 students who work closely.
This was from one of the important synergies between Aims
3 and Aim 1. And we also taught a health equity course to basic
scientists and to medical students.
What did we learn? Well, we've learned a lot of things.
We found that working with community organizations is critical
to build trust, to really focus on
collaborations, and work through a lot of the issues,
particularly as we moved into
how you go about really creating
expectations around deliverables and finance,
and really working through those actual
negotiations. The other key piece about
this is that
as we work through all that, but resources are critical
for this kind of work to happen, and really being able to
find ongoing resources for community to continue this kind of work
is critical and remains a challenge.
We learned that community members are interested in getting trained about clinical
research and to become community scientists.
We learned that the majority of patients are actually open to the idea
of clinical trials, and that there was not a racial ethnic
disparity in attitudes towards clinical research and clinical
trials. And we also found that we did not see
a racial ethnic difference in
who the docs talked to about clinical trials.
We found, as many have, and is well known, that minority patients
are less likely to be eligible for clinical trials.
And we also found that it's possible to match trials to patients
and not just patients to trials.
We found that timing is critical. Timing is critical for
algorithm accuracy, and
it's also critical for patients'
abilities to even hear about the possibility
of participating in research, even when they may be open to
it, to the idea of it.
That's really important when you think about interventions that we would need to
do moving forward, because this is not a knowledge
issue. This is an emotional issue.
And so educating about clinical trials is really not going to help solve that
challenge.
We learned a lot about text messaging because we wanted to do text
messaging to get at the population that wasn't enrolled in MyChart,
which is part of the patient portal for Epic.
There were actually a lot of problems with that, starting with wrong telephone
numbers and some of the structures within Epic that made that essentially
impossible.
And then,
the big problem, which everybody knows about, is there's a
huge mismatch between the kinds of trials that are
open and available to patients and what the patient's clinical
characteristics are. So we had a lot more early-stage
patients than we had trials available for early-stage patients.
And to get at that, we tried. We had a networking
event where we actually invited pharma along with a whole bunch of the
researchers, both basic and translational, and patients in community.
And I got to say, pharma got quite an earful from community
about
the need to open up trials, and potential ways of doing this
were really discussed in the different work groups, but it really has a long way to
go.
And I just want to end by thanking our
incredible
community partners, our clinical partners, our
educational partners. This really has been
a project filled with incredible devotion,
love, work. And so many people made this possible
because all of them were needed. This is the community
out in the communities, but the clinical communities,
people were really open and
really open to participating and really trying to change the
system. So I just wanted to acknowledge that.
Thank you.
Any
questions?
Questions from the floor. I see Bill coming up. Great.
So the tool you developed to screen for
what kind of people would participate in what kind of trial seems
especially helpful in the scheme of things.
If you look at our nation's cancer centers,
Rob's looking at me. I'm like, the EAB of 25% of them or something at this
point. One of the things they are supposed to do when they think of
launching a clinical trial with the help of one of our pharma friends or not,
is they're supposed to prospectively say, "This is the number of people we are
likely to see who would be eligible and we're going to accrue."
Mm-hmm.
And yet, I can tell you that this is one of the biggest stumbling blocks at most
of our country's cancer centers. They do the wrong trials for the wrong people.
Mm-hmm.
Oftentimes, they do stupid trials, which is a different issue altogether that you
don't have to deal with. But they definitely do the wrong trials for the wrong
people. They don't launch trials for the people that they're
actually seeing.
Your tool should not have been a surprise to them, but it's a good tool.
What I was wondering, have you thought about using it prospectively along with the
people as they begin to launch the trials or with IRB approval or something?
Well, this was all prospective.
Just FYI, but...
No, I mean prospectively to the people who haven't yet proposed a trial.
Say, "Look, this is who you're seeing."
Yeah.
So we've been working closely with our cancer center director, trying to
figure out how we can now really...
Because we've built all the infrastructure,
so how can
we embed this so that they can use it?
Because it's there for them to use.
So it is a work in progress.
Yeah. Thank you. Marie-Pierre St-Laurent from Vancouver in Canada.
I do research. I'm a physician, and trying to see what
can be used about what you presented. It's quite interesting.
A few technical questions. The tool you've talked about in the first part,
how long before the appointment with the physician will that education take place?
Just in terms of making it for the patients, kind of integrating and
not being overwhelming.
Is that potential ways of educating the patients to research
available in a way?
So,
happy to make it available.
The way that we ended up figuring out how to do this
was... And the reason I'm not giving you a straight answer is because it varied.
What we aimed to do was first we
talked to all the docs and a bunch of the
nurses, management, front desk, everybody, to get a sense of, as
Jim was talking about, workflows and
timing, and when did they want to get this kind of information and
how.
So the ideal was, and the
compromise was that we would
identify
patients at that first visit when they were either a new patient or
had evidence of disease progression.
And we would consent them,
at that time and feedback information prior to the
next visit, the second visit, because theoretically,
that first visit was to talk about the cancer for new
patients,
and potential treatments. And the second one was going to be to talk about
actual treatments and make the decisions what would happen.
What ended up happening is that, in fact, most of the
decisions were being made at that first visit.
So we needed to get this information to the docs and the
patients,
even before they saw the docs.
So what we did
for breast was we actually had to consent the surgeons
so that we could get this information to the med oncs and the
patients before they saw the med onc.
We had to actually individualize this with each of the med
oncs because some of them didn't want us approaching their patients until they
actually saw them.
So
I'd say we were pretty successful,
at being able to get the information to the docs
before they saw these patients, mostly for
the first time.
For those where they didn't want it, we had to wait until they
actually saw the patients, and then we'd send it.
Or like for the liver docs,
because they didn't have that many trials open anyway, we sent them the list of
what those trials were, so at least they could have it.
We also sent out a best practice alert at the visit when they were seeing
the patient, theoretically for that treatment decision making.
And we'd send out a BPA that had the embedded link in there so they could
get that individualized patient's match list.
So as close as possible,
mostly at that first visit.
Thank you.
All right. Well, thank you very much.
And we'll have Dr.
Winn come up to finish us out as a session.
Okay. So first of all, I want to thank you all for being here.
I do want to thank,
unapologetically,
Stand Up To Cancer and Bristol Myers Squibb and others, Genentech and others, for
actually really understanding of how to advance the science.
This field of health disparities is not a political one, but a
real scientific one of which I'm proud to
lend my voice.
I do want to actually remind people about how this project came on.
This is Bold Approaches to Lung Cancer Screening.
But really, this came about because there was this
amazing RFA that came out from Stand Up To
Cancer that we responded to.
How are we going to actually tackle one of the big problems that we have in the
country in the context of particularly minorities and, in this case, lung
cancer screening? This is a story of Ray Dubois and I
first having this conversation about, "Wait a minute, you're in South
Carolina. I'm in Virginia. Ooh, wouldn't this be great?"
And it was Ray who then actually said, "We're missing somebody."
And that somebody was Shelley Earp at the time.
And so the three cancer centers got together and said, "Wait a minute,
we
have not only a great story, but a purpose." The purpose
was that we sit along what's called the I-95 corridor.
And for those of you who don't know, that I-95 corridor from Virginia to North
Carolina, South Carolina, was once called the Corridor of Shame.
It was called the Corridor of Shame because we had the lowest education
rating within that whole region and the highest
poorest outcomes from things like asthma, cardiovascular disease, and clearly
cancer.
But I always want to remind people that in...
I think Bill and Julian and John, you'll know where I'm going next
with this, is that when we had Shelley Earp, there was a, we call the fourth
Beatle, or what was the silent Beatle, or the silent Stone?
There was a woman by the name of Joanne Earp,
who was married to Shelley.
Many of you may not know her name, but many, hopefully, you recall that
Joanne, in the '90s, with the Breast Cancer Consortium, which she started
along the I-95, really brought this whole attention to the fact that in the
South, while there were lots of technologies, there were not things happening in
the South, particularly along that I-95 corridor.
She brought it about herself to really bring this whole issue around mammography,
breast cancer screening. I want to give a shout-out to, actually,
Joanne Earp. When I think of the power coupleIn
science that actually has the most romantic story
about how their love of science brought them together and what they did, it's the
Erbs.
By the way, before I begin, I want to actually let you know that I wrote this down
because Shelly actually told me this, and it actually moved me. He said, "Dr.
Erb once sort of said about Joanne at a meeting," which was the
coolest thing. He said, "I want to thank Joanne for keeping public health and human
concerns at the forefront of my work, which helped me build a
premier program in cancer health disparities."
What I want to tell you about this program is that ultimately this is not an
activity. This was really a passion
for addressing an issue.
So with this, I would like to say that we also picked lung
cancer, and these are my disclosures.
But we picked lung cancer specifically because at that time, while there
was certainly a reduction in the context of
the different outcome between Blacks and whites around lung cancer, it still
remained that lung cancer was the number one killer in the United States, by the
way. And if you looked at the group that actually suffered more, it was African
Americans. We actually sort of said, again, science isn't just
because we wanted to find something cool.
We were thinking about the impact, the academic relevance of our work to this
region.
This is the team that I want to let you know that we actually finally convinced to
do the work. It was Marvella Ford, and Louise
Henderson. Henderson from UNC and Marvella from
MUSC Hollings. This team, I would tell that those two
people, Louise and Marvella, are not me.
I'm essentially just the pale person sort of saying, the
lighter of the three. Those two women have been carrying the weight of this
program and have been fantastic and have been the most amazing partners I've had.
In addition to that, we've had people from our VCU, Dr.
Long,
folks like Dr. Silvestri, Dr. Nanosinkam, Dr. Tan, Dr.
Shepherd, and Dr. Wheeler, who've all come together as a team to solve
the problem within the I-95 corridor about how do we find data
that makes it better.
Also, before I get going, want to let you know that I'm going to only focus on one
aim, but there were two.
Highlight. The first aim was, could we get people to get
screened,
particularly in rural
areas? Now, most of you, when you think of rural areas and you think of urban
challenges, but when you think of rural, you tend to think of Green Acres, for
those of you who are old enough,
where it's a very homogeneous group.
But I'm telling you, what I loved about this program is it brought out
also the intersectionality of rural,
so that when we think of the type of rurality that's in Utah or
Maine, we also think of the type of rurality that's in the I-95
corridor, which is predominantly African American.
I want you to think about as we launch into this program, and we did have Joanne
Erb, who honestly was good for all three of us.
She would occasionally sit us down and sort of say, "Now, you know this work is
important. You've got to get this right." So I have to give Joanne
some credit about this. So what we wound up doing is we wound up having
patient advocate and early career investigators like Dr. Tosis, Dr. Brenner, Dr.
Fox. We've had a number of amazing patient advocates, in
this case, Rudeen Marissa Haynes and Diane, who just turned out to be wonderful.
But let's get to it.
Our first aim, could we even get people screened, particularly
in rural areas of Virginia, of North
Carolina,
and areas in South Carolina? And the second part was, wait a minute, we
had a great idea. And I'm going to give Ray this sort of credit.
He says, "Well, if we're getting people screened,
we could as the SEC," the other SEC,
the Southeastern Consortium, "could we all of a sudden
do something even bigger with both arms?" In addition to
figuring out how do we get people screened, what if we actually also focused on our
second arm of figuring out if we can, one, not only create the largest
repository of African American tissue and samples,
but also come up with a signal
that would help us be able to better predict
who we need to actually take action on sooner.
I'm going to focus because of time.
I'm going to focus on aim one, but I want to tell you, we have
publications that will show you with aim one, but we have some hot
publications. Apparently, that's why I'm not talking about it today, because it's
hot and it's going to be off the press about looking at various SNPs and why
they're important. I won't talk about that today.
As a result of this team, we actually put this
paper out from the American...
We did a blue journal about addressing disparities in lung cancer screening
eligibility and health care. And as you can see, we had everybody from Patricia
Rivera, all the big folk, trying to figure out how can
we address this issue of getting more people screened, particularly in rural areas.
This SEC,
as we like to call it, that Southeastern Conference,
were very similar. When we looked at that I-95 corridor, we actually had
over 19 million people within that.
About 28% were African American. The
counties, when you think about the rural, that
was the majority of what we saw. So not only was this an issue of the context
of African Americans in this study, but really, it's trying to address
for America that rurality is very different.
What you see in the West, what you see in the South, what you see in the Northeast
and the Midwest, they're sharing some commonalities, but there's
some challenges. What I loved about this study is that it started to
unlock some of those issues as well.
Our smoking rates pretty much throughout the context, you can sort of see here, is
worse than the average within the US in obesity and
other things, but we'll just kind of stay here.
Aim one was to initiate and evaluate high impact, what
we thought at the time was really cool, and now we're learning from the group
that's actually on this panel,
great minds think alike. This concept of
multimodalMulti-level navigation,
meaning that we not only thought about our traditional navigators, our
nurse navigators, but we also played with the term of initially,
what we would call community activators.
About how do you identify people within a community that could actually activate
the system to sort of get folks navigated.
We thought that we had a really cool thing, because
we could look at certainly rural, which was our commitment, but we also
were able to balance that off with also some urban areas as
well. Aim two, which we're not going to talk about today, but has
resulted, I think, in a really some cool science as well.
We were to develop a robust shared population-based cohort and
biorepository to further support research in understanding
the biological determinants or risk factors for poor lung
cancer outcomes. And in fact, we think we actually, as many of you know, there's
PLCO and lots of other screening sort of things about predictive risks and
all the rest of these other things. We think we're onto something.
We won't talk about that today.
This takes partners, and as many of you sort of said, federally qualified health
centers are not just a part of the story, but across the
United States, I am going to make the pitch and say it unapologetically,
that when we don't involve
actually FQHCs and community health centers throughout the country, we've lost a
lot.
There is a lot of there, there, in those communities.
Now, what I will say
is that you're going to look at the methods here.
Ultimately,
I tried to identify
675 African Americans that were eligible for a
lung cancer screening.
And ultimately, this is essentially the flowchart of how we got there.
I'm not going to spend a whole lot of time.
Actually, Marvella Ford, this is her baby here.
But what I will say is that, at the end of the day, we've learned a
whole lot by ultimately going through these issues of
using phones, of using other different types of ways of getting...
But at the end of the day, it turns out that the navigation team, the good
old-fashioned foot traffic of knocking on doors and getting
out to people is really pretty effective.
This is what we sort of sampled, our recent accomplishments.
As you can sort of see here, we have over 5,000 samples.
We've
contacted over 3,000 people. And as you can see here, we've
ultimately had around 220 folks enrolled.
This has really been a busy slide, but what I can tell you
here is that there is a training toolkit that we
developed for our navigators.
And when people... I think if someone said that this is
not done top-down. This wasn't done as we are the great academic
institutions developing this toolkit.
This was literally co-created with folks from the community, which I
really liked.
Next, these are a couple of papers that have come out of that, "Advancing
Equity and Diagnostic Excellence to Reduce Health Disparities." That was in
one of the papers. And we also had a second paper in "Cancer" that
just came out around design and interim recruitment outcomes from multi-modal,
multi-level patient navigation and enrichment lung cancer,
for our Southeast consortium. What I loved about this program in
particular is that I don't think under normal circumstances we would have gotten
the three of us together
to actually address this issue along the I-95 had it not been for
the call of action from this
grant.
The second thing that happened,
which again, I wish I could talk more about it, is that I don't think we would have
come up with this new way of risk reduction or risk screening
and having a biomarker to actually let us know who's
actually more at risk without actually the call of someone thinking
ahead like, "Man, this would be a cool thing.
Why can't we address it?" So again, I have to thank you guys for giving us the
opportunity.
This was a poster that we presented
back at the AACR Health Disparities Meeting a little bit ago.
And ultimately, what I love about it as a conclusion is that it's
not just a lot of stuff that actually having
focused multi-level navigation, we now call
transdisciplinary science and all this, but literally involving the community right
from the beginning and actually being organized and coordinated among
multiple centers, turns out
you can get more people actually into screening.
These are all of our partners. It takes a village to sort of
do these things.
But I think in reflecting on this program, I think I just
have to stand here for a moment and sort of say that it has
been eye-opening that
just because we have a lung
screening program and we want to get people in it, it turns out that that's not
enough. It turns out that actually one size fits all, and I
love the fact that you guys talked about when you've seen one FQHC, you've seen one
FQHC. But the crazy thing is, when you think about rural communities, whether
you're talking about rugged rural, we have not dealt with frontier country yet,
because that was just not within our call, but along that I-95, I
think we not only got signals about some of the issues with African Americans, but
it turns out that we also got, as a secondary
gain, if you will, lots of really good information about
rural communities
and how to get them better served. So I know that
this is the end of the day and you guys have got other places
to go.
I just wanted to share with you Aim 1 because I thought that this whole concept
of coordination with the community and coordination
almost on a every other week basis with
organizing our activities along the I-95 with the three academic
centersAnd then coordinating that with our
FQHCs has led to more people
getting screened. By the way, when you look at MUSC and they start
looking at, almost like Kentucky, how are we doing since the program started, you
can see that we've moved the needle.
So I want to thank you for
paying attention and staying with me on this.
I also want to tell you that the concept of
multi-modal navigation and not just having the
old-fashioned, here's the community healthcare workers, here's our nurse
navigators, but expanding that is a time
to think about how can we reimagine navigation.
Future directions. So for us, the future directions are going to be how we
can, based on the data that we have, how we're going to level up and think
about even more creative ways of doing even more
out-of-the-box navigation,
particularly in the context of rural communities to make it work.
How we can, I think someone's talked about using AI and some are
using technology, but here is my pitch to you.
I don't really give a hootenanny, a very Southern term, I've picked that
up,
about your technology if it doesn't have an
infrastructure behind it and underneath of it to make it work.
Another way of saying that is that what we've discovered from this program is that
while we are driving high tech, we also need to drive high
touch,
and both need infrastructure. We think about the AI
machine learning infrastructure, and we're so accustomed to talking about the
infrastructure that's needed to do that, but for the high touch, it
also is going to require a different level of thinking
around the infrastructure to support it.
And I think that once we reach the high tech, high touch sort of
zone, we'll be able to really do what we're trying to do, which is to make
impact.
The second thing I want to tell you is that as we're leaning into
thinking about the SNPs that I would like to share, but I think once the paper
comes out, I'll make sure all you guys get it.
It's really cool. It turns out that having
polyrisk scores and all the rest of the stuff, that it turns out
that we may have not been thinking about this correctly about certain communities,
not blacks. I want to also tell you that this is not just a DNA
issue, it's a ZNA issue, a zip code neighborhood association, and that what you're
seeing here would apply, we believe, the findings we have here would also apply to
white rural communities as well.
We are leaning into this interesting thing, though, this next phase in which we're
going to be using AI imaging
along with what we've actually had with the SNPs to sort of see if we can make it
more powerful of identifying not only who to screen, but who to really
worry about. So, I'm going to end there and just tell you, if I
seem super excited about this program, I was.
If I'm even more super excited about what I think part two is going to look like,
I'm even more excited about even part two.
What I want to tell you is that
this concept of high tech, high touch is hopefully a
concept whose time has come.
Infrastructure is critical for both the
advancement of science on both the technological side, but
equally interested in the implementation sciences of the
infrastructure needed for touch and impact.
So I'll stop there and take any questions.
I may have worn you out, but you never know.
Thank you.
Rob, great talk as always, and very inspirational.
It seemed to me that the navigators were key to making all of this work.
What happens when the funding ends and the grants... Who will pay?
How do you
keep the navigators in place without
adequate funding, and how are you thinking about
solving this problem?
So I probably shouldn't say this publicly, but I am going to say it publicly.
I'm actually using the data and the effectiveness of this to drive to our health
systems that actually says from a cost impact sort of
perspective, that the navigation in the end of the day was a positive,
not a negative-
Right
... for the health system. So I actually am driving these data.
I know it's supposed to be purely academic, but actually some of this data, Ray and
I have discussed, that some of the data's actually been helpful for us to
use to our health system that says, "This is why a navigation
program actually matters. And in fact, it doesn't
cost you as much as you think it does, and here's the downstream benefit."
So I know we weren't supposed to use this study for that specifically,
but the practical aspect of what the data we're now using, we're
actually using that to make the pitch for health systems about why they should be
doing and thinking about this as an approach.
We will be thinking about, as you know, you may not know, but, as a result
of this, we actually are putting together, and starting to think
about putting together a PO1
with the three institutions and about how we can actually move forward.
But I'm really happy about the data that came out, that it's practical data
that go to health systems and says, "You do know that having these extra
navigators cost you almost next to nothing,
but actually has this benefit at the end of the funnel."
But we'll see.
Thanks.
Okay.
Rob, Doug Lowy from NCI.
I have two questions related to navigation.
The first is,
I assume perhaps incorrectly, that you are
focused on stationary
radiology for doing your helical CT screening.
Have you also considered mobile vans
doing this? And my second question is, one of the big problems
with lung cancer screening is compliance.
Do you think that the navigation is going to really make a
difference here?
Dr. Lowe, as always, you have not only great questions, but you
remind me of what I forgot to tell you in the talk. So thank you, sir.
The other benefit of this was because we employed not just
a standard navigation model, but the multi, was that we had a group of
them to go back
and actually do the issue with the follow-up that we hadn't had before.
And so what we saw was the rates of the first, but then coming back for the
second, actually increased as a direct result of
having a different type of navigation program.
I really
like the mobile because that came up, particularly in rural communities like
West Virginia, for example, or some other programs, that we've relied on
stationary. The problem with the stationary issue is that we have transportation
issue.
And so we had to overcome some of those transportation issues to
sort of get things done. But to your point, had we been really
clever and being able to do a multi-source
mobile and stationary, I think our numbers would've been better, but we did
not actually have any mobile vans.
But I could assume that in places like rugged
rural areas, which was not really South
Carolina or North Carolina, but there are those rugged rural areas.
I would say that if we probably tried to do the same thing in a rugged rural area
without the mobile vans like they have in West Virginia, our numbers would've been
lower.
Hi, Dr. Winn. I am from rural Tennessee, so I
appreciate the Hootenanny, and I certainly understood that.
However, you did mention multimodal, and I didn't
quite understand that, and I was hoping that you would please
elaborate on what you were meaning by
multimodal-
Yeah
... methods of contact. I did appreciate also the high tech, high
touch.
Yeah.
Thank you.
So we traditionally relied on nurse
navigators.
Mm-hmm.
We leaned into that heavily. But what I found out was with nurse
navigators, you actually had to be in the system, and then they can navigate
you through the system.
Mm-hmm.
And then we had a level of navigation that was
community health workers.
Mm-hmm.
Which was not always defined, in the context
of exactly where they were going and what they were doing, how do they actually
help us with follow-up, right? But I know Harold P.
Freeman and other people have done amazing things with navigation.
We did have a third one. So this arm was supposed to be...
And it came from the following. When I have really incredibly wealthy
donors,
they don't have to have training.
They essentially activate a system that they call either the
cancer center director or a friend, and then they get a system activated for
them so that they can go from their community and be navigated
to our health system, and ultimately get through a health system to get something
done.
That equivalent was lost to me in these neighborhoods and particularly rural areas.
Mm.
So the attempt of calling it multimodal was really kind of being a
little cute, but it was just extending on the context of really thinking about
community health workers as not always having to be certified, but actually working
with them so that they're certified enough so that we had three groups.
A group that could activate, a group that could then, once
activated, get you from the community
into the health system, and then once you're in the health system, a group that can
navigate you through the end of getting these things followed.
By the way, I think we
not failed, we just didn't have enough resources.
But we were also trying to include financial toxicity and financial
advisors, navigation within this group too.
We
didn't
have a muscular response on that because I think we were just so
focused on trying to get this done.
But if we were to do it in the best, that's a piece of
it that's missing. We wanted to make sure that navigation
wasn't one size fits all, that when it comes to financial, when it comes to some
social, that we actually had expertise in each of those, and that they worked
as a team as opposed to sort of saying, "Well, I don't know what happened to the
nurse navigator." It was, what happened to the team of navigators-
Mm-hmm
... to get someone through the system. So that was the wrinkle.
And I don't know if that helps or confuses things, but it was just that we thought
as it is, it wasn't
as effective as it could be if we actually had more of a team model of navigation
as opposed to a navigation person.
Mm-hmm. No, that's perfect. Thank you so much.
Okay.
I think we have time for one more question.
Good. That's good because there's only one more person. Yeah.
So,
excellent talk as always.
I have a comment and then a question.
The comment is a little bit more
general,
in the sense that for navigators,
I've been running about a repository for many, many
years.
It's about timing as well, and persistence.
And I think we tend to think about
how we approach the patients
very monolithically.
And we really have to kind of adapt more and kind of
go outside of the boxes, you said a couple of times, in order to
try to
enact some of these strategies to get the patients on board.
It's not simple.
The idea's great, but it's not simple. Now to do my question.
This just doesn't require any comment.
Pink and Pearl has had some very interesting findings, and
we just
went through a couple different talks on different types of cancers,
and they all face their own challenges.
But I think that we're thinking about this all incorrectly in the
sense that, okay, maybe we get them screened for colorectal, maybe we get them
screened for lung,
but then they get breast cancer, and they die from breast cancerWhy
can't we pull these things together?
And I don't mean that in the sense of
multi-cancer blood tests, because I think
maybe, I don't know, we can debate that when we're not in front of a microphone
later.
Yeah.
But
there are very practical ways that
screening vans and mammography,
maybe we cover them both with the same scan.
And maybe we're getting coronary artery disease in there, too. That's a killer.
Why aren't we talking about that? And so are we thinking about this all incorrectly
is my question, and that's-
Yeah
... for everyone.
So your question is a very good one because we are still thinking about all of
these things, including our AI, in a very 20th century sort of perspective.
If it were up to me, I would do bundle.
And I think that this is something that, Dr.
Loy, hopefully you won't throw a shoe at me or anything about that.
But there's been going back and forth for the last X number of years about when you
have at-risk populations, why aren't we bundling?
When you think about hypertension, when you think about diabetes, when you think
about cancer screening, all the rest of this stuff, if there were a national model
to do it. So it's not that we don't think about it, it's
just that we don't have the national model at this point or the infrastructure
or the industries to actually all align these things.
That's why I'm very interested in what's happening in Germany right now, where they
have... I mean, they have some very interesting thing in Australia and Germany
about getting people screened and sort of thinking out loud about bundling.
And to your first point, we think so much comfortably on precision
medicine and NGS, but we don't think about
precision community efforts.
I think it's time to start thinking about, I'm going to use a phrase from Dr.
Tosis, the missing omics aren't just lipid omics and genomics,
they're also the omics within community.
And if we start really using catchment area data as a
science to actually help guide us with more filling in the data, I think
we can actually have even better strategies.
So I'm hoping that the concept of catchment area data sciences or
catchment area whatever, or area of what you're taking care of impact, that
that science continue to help as we have these new tools so that we can actually
have much more of
a precise way of impacting our community. So thank you for that. Appreciate it.
Thanks.
So I just want to thank everybody for being here.
And on behalf of Stand Up To Cancer, I want to thank all of our
panelists on these wonderful projects. So one last time, let's give them applause.
Thank you.